hey everyone developer here and in
today's video we're diving back into the
creative and ever-expanding world of
jiu-jitsu kaizen to do this we're going
to start exactly where the anime has
left us at the end of the death
paintings arc or more specifically right
before the start of currently my second
favorite arc and the greatest backstory
to any character introduced so far
throughout this world this here is the
heartbreaking and tear-jerking but yet
still somehow beautiful gojo past ark or
hidden inventory arc of juju kaizen of
course if you are new around here and
want to watch other explained content
just like this but for a variety of
different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with their algorithm
and pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
let's finally get into the world of
jujutsu kaizen
so as the arc starts off we find
ourselves 12 years earlier in the past
with a younger and still voluptuous
grade one sorcerer meimei along with the
second grade sorcerer udahime where they
have been tasked to investigate a cursed
mansion in hamumatsu city unfortunately
both of them get caught within a barrier
that somehow overlap space itself the
girls deduce this after traveling inside
of this mansion for 15 kilometers
without seeing any of the markers that
they had left behind because their walls
are so squishy upon impact udahi may
decide that they should split up and
move more unpredictably to escape the
barrier however just before the girls
are able to put their plan into action
the house is suddenly torn apart by the
cursed technique lapse bloom as udahime
recovers from the sudden eruption
jujutsu high's second year student
satoru gojo appears in front of her he
asks if she's crying annoying urahime
and meimei also mocks her asking gojo if
he would console her should the sorcerer
cry goju believes meimei wouldn't cry
though and just before udahime is able
to berate him a giant curse appears
behind her funnily enough though
instantly after the curse appears an
even larger curse appears behind it to
devour it also there jijusu hai's second
year student sukudu gesso orders his
curse to not eat the other one just yet
so that he can absorb and assimilate it
later he tells satoru it's not nice to
pick on weight claims like udahime to
which gojo points out that suguru is
teasing odahime without even realizing
herds their classmate shoko also arrives
with them much to the excitement of
udahime apparently meimei and udhime
were trapped in a rare type of barrier
that messes with space-time itself the
other students were sent by yaga as it
was odd that a grade one sorcerer hadn't
made contact with them for a few days
meimei immediately asks where the
curtain is shocking all of these
students who had completely forgot to
put up a barrier baka jiu jutsu tech
soon after news of a so-called explosion
that destroyed the mansion makes the
news grade one sorcerer and currently
the first year teacher masamichi yaga
questions the three students one of them
said that they had put up a curtain and
then left their manager behind shoko and
suguru are quick to point gojo out
however gojo complains that curtains are
pointless since civilians can't see jiu
jitsu or curses anyway suguru argues
that it's important that regular humans
can't see sorcerers to provide a peace
of mind and hide the existence of curses
goku believes it is a pain looking out
for the weak but suguru believes that
jujutsu itself exists to protect
non-sorcerers however goju disagrees and
hates those righteous ideals which
begins to annoy gethou as the argument
begins to heat up masa mitchu returns to
the class and the boys instantly change
their outwards attitude he then assigns
them to a mission together that comes
straight from master tengen he says that
there is a girl who was a perfect match
for master tengan who is known as the
star plasma vessel yaka tells the boys
that they must escort the girl to master
tengen and then erase her their boys
joke with each other agreeing that yaga
has led his promotion to the next
principle of this school drive him crazy
suguru puts the jokes aside though and
asks if the mission is meant to reset
master tengan's curse technique gojo
isn't sure what they're referring to
when it's something that he thinks he
should obviously know yaga explains that
tengan is immortal but his curse
technique does not stop the aging
process once a certain age is reached
evolution will occur and master tengen
will no longer be the same person
yaga explains that tengan strengthens
all of the barriers used by both jujutsu
high schools as well as the auxiliary
managers techniques every 500 years
master tengen must merge with a
compatible star plasma vessel and
rewrite his body's information once the
body is refreshed the immortal curse
technique will stop trying to change
bodies and evolution will not occur
zadaru compares the situation to digimon
which suffices in this case
the location of the star plasma vessel
has been leaked and there are two groups
that are currently searching for the
girl
one is the cursed user group q who wants
to take over the jujutsu world by having
master tengen lose all reason the other
is a star religious group that worships
tengan as their god known as the time
vessel association tengan and his star
plasma vessel must emerge in two days
when the moon is full gojo and ghetto
leave for their mission and discuss why
the star religious group is after the
star plasma vessel sugu explains that
they worship a pure master tengen and
that the merchant would sully the purity
in their eyes however they are not a
cursed user group and suguru believes
that they won't be major players he says
that they should focus on repelling q to
which gojo believes that they should be
fine no matter what since they are the
strongest suguru interrupts his friend
to advise him to be less rude around his
superiors while they discuss sedaro's
bad attitude there is an explosion at
the site where they are meant to find
the girl
suddenly the star plasma vessel is
thrown from the building by someone from
queue named kokon
before the girl hits the ground though
suguru uses a flying curse to rescue her
he asks the curse user to not make a
mess since these students already got in
trouble today
cocoon demands that the jiu-jitsu high
students hand over the girl but sugeru
refuses
saturday watches from below glad that
sugu made it in time he notices though
five daggers thrown at him and uses
technique infinity to halt them another
q soldier named bayer confronts him and
admits that he knows the name of the
famous satoru gojo
goju taunts the soldier and says that he
won't beat him senseless if he cries and
apologizes now elsewhere at a similar
time chewie kong a representative of the
time vessel association meets with a
member of the zenon clan to plan an
assassination of this star plasma vessel
however the man claims that he is no
longer a zenin and instead goes by toji
for shiguro now he then accepts the
contract to kill the girl
back at the battle sugru effortlessly
immobilizes cocoon with a curse that
wants to kiss him cocoon promises to
quit being a curse user and grow rice on
the countryside if ghetto lets him go
suguru ignores him further irritating
cocoon and the q soldier threatens their
buyer q's stronger soldier will come and
kill them all however gido soon shows
cocoon a picture with bayer defeated on
his phone
with q's strongest soldier defeated the
organization soon disbands meanwhile
kong from the star religious group finds
toji betting on a horse race apparently
he used 30 million yen in advance to
wear down gojo and the sorcerer is with
him slightly confused by his actions the
representative needs to bring back a
report to his client and remain
skeptical of toji however toji is
confident he'll get a return on their
money for sure but he ends up losing
some of his bets on the horse races
the representative reminds the sorcerer
that he's counting on him and before he
leaves he asks toji how megami is doing
batoche literally couldn't care less and
he can't even remember who that is at
this point back with gojo and ghetto we
are finally introduced to rico who
awakens and satoru's arms and
immediately attacks him she believes
them to be her attackers until her
caretaker masato arrives all three of
them then get on the same page and rico
begins to discuss her connection to
master tengen in casual fashion though
the two boys ignore her and then she
realizes that she's currently running
late for school rather than take her
back to jiu jitsu high now riko ends up
back at rinchoku girls high school due
to the orders from master tengen they
are told to oblige rico's requests
because she will no longer exist after
this merger it is their mission to allow
her to enjoy herself which masado is
thankful for moments later suguru checks
his surveillance curses and realizes
that two of them had already been taken
out they both had to find enrico
immediately while at the same time two
curse users trespass on the campus it is
revealed that toji had used a dark
website for curse users to place a 30
million dollar bounty on rico's head and
these men have come to collect their
bounty taji sits on the phone with kong
while eating at a dumpling stand he
learns that these sorceress protecting
rico have not returned to jiu-jitsu high
this is good for the time vessel
association because now more than just
total lunatics will go after the bounty
the representative points out that the
30 million paid to him was a service fee
so if someone else kills the star plasma
vessel toji may end up losing all of the
money fushiguro though isn't worried as
he knows gojo will take care of anyone
who comes after them satoru gojo is the
first in a hundred years of the gojo
family to wield both these six eyes and
the limitless curse technique toji is
not even sure that he could take out the
star placement vessel with gojo still
present he plans on using curse users
for the remaining 39 hours of the
mission to wear down gojo's group it
will be free labor since no one will be
able to cash in on the bounty
the representative realises that this
makes the limit of two days turn out in
their favor additionally it makes it
easier for them to gather cursed users
togi says they are moving faster than he
expected and he'll move out soon as well
he tells the rep to have that 30 million
ready but the man wants to talk about
his cart which disinterests toji erin
choku girls junior high satoru suguru
and masato moved to find rico who was at
a musical class which is either taking
place in the music room or at the
chairpool suguru plans on heading
straight for the intruders while
saturday and masato split up to find
riko gojo was irritated because he
wanted to stay close to the girl masato
apologises as rico didn't want to be
seen with boys as an all-girls school
suguru splits off on his own wondering
who these curse users could be with
without q around hired muscle for the
time vessel association could be trouble
getting makes a turn down a hallway and
encounters an old gentleman who
immediately covers his front and rear
wishikagami the cursed user recognizes
sugar's uniform and assumes that there
are multiple opponents ghetto notices
this and understands that his opponent
knows what he is doing his opponent
analyzes him as well recognizing the
student's curse technique as some sort
of cursed manipulation
the old man keeps up his conversation
with suguru while plotting to get in
close range however ghetto tells him to
not waste his time and uses his giant
worm-like curse to fill the entire
hallway suguru believes he's one but the
cursed user appears from the window
behind him using the blind spot his
opponent created to his advantage he
gets within close range of suguru and
believes that he has the advantage
however his life randomly and instantly
flashes before his eyes sukuru dominates
the old man in close quarters and beats
him senselessly with a ferocious
succession of quick strikes he
recognises that the old man wanted to
get in close and states that fighters
who are presented with a single way to
win are easily to manipulate he
questions the old man asking if he is
aligned with q or the time vessel
association
elsewhere the others continue to head
towards rico who is currently in the
chapel gojo barges into the chapel
yelling for rico surprising everyone
inside and embarrassing her the young
girls inside are enthralled by how cute
gojo is so they start asking rico
questions saturday even takes over
sunglasses for them annoying rico with
his confidence the teacher makes the
girl settle down and momentarily scolds
gojo before giving away her number while
other girls continue to argue saturday
grabs rico and escapes the chapel with
her she's annoyed he didn't follow her
request but he explains to her that
curse users have attacked the school
goju wants to head straight for jiujitsu
high but as he runs across one of the
rooftops with a girl he is spotted by a
curse user the curse user though doesn't
recognize the guy that is with her but
recognizes the girl masato confronts the
curse user from behind and asks if he is
worth the time vessel association or q
they engage in a short scuffle but it
ends shortly after masato beats up the
man by striking him below the belt
guitar arrived shortly after completely
surprised by her strength based on the
conversation the paper bag curse user is
able to confirm that the girl he saw is
the bounty suddenly he melts into a
puddle of mud making masato question if
he really was a shikagami suguru calls
saturdo and informs him that there is a
30 million yen bounty on rico's head
with a time limit on a dark website for
cursed users satoru understands and
hangs up the phone immediately as he and
rico are surrounded by four of these
same curse users riko also thinks that
the curse uses clones ashikagami while
gojo says that their opponent should be
a jiu-jitsu sorcerer the curse usually
refuses and forms a fifth clone claiming
being a professional sorcerer is more
dangerous than it's worth while the new
doppelganger is forming gojo attacks
quickly and uses his curse technique
lapse blue to quickly take out two
people in an instant riko notices that
the shukagami haven't been dispelled and
gojo corrects her saying that they are
not shikigami instead they are clones of
the real techniques caster two of the
clones getting close to satoru but they
can't bypass his infinity making them
easy prey for a counter-attack thanks to
his six eyes zato was able to read his
opponent's curse technique and decides
to divulge his own allowing him to
create a magnetic force that brings the
curse users closer to him
satsuru attempts to unleash the cursed
technique reversal of the limitless but
it doesn't work instead he is forced to
knock out his opponent with a punch
confusing rico suddenly she gets a text
with a picture of masato captured by the
enemy sugu apologises to rico and gojo
for leaving masato behind without
considering her importance to the enemy
saturda believes that their enemy will
try to pull off a trade he knows that
they have the upper hand and plans on
coordinating with their opponents to
rescue masato riku refuses because she
hasn't gotten to see her goodbyes yet
and worries that the merge will happen
beforehand goju assumes that the enemy
will contact them soon and agrees to
bring riko along as long as she isn't
scared or lowers the chances of masato's
survival the kidnappers demand onikawa
is their meeting spot once there sasaru
suguru and rico are able to rescue
masato and apprehend the kidnappers at
the beach masato apologises for being
captured by a non-sorcery member of the
time vessel association
suguru shares blame with her and
explains that they were able to travel
safely on a plane aided by their
abilities they wondered why onikawa was
chosen as their mating spot and masada
suggests that maybe it's so that they
could attack the airport however it has
explained that jiu-jitsu high took
precautions by sending in the other
first year's first yu hayabada and kento
nanami to guard the premises while both
of them are committed to do their duty
at the airport saturday messes around
with rico and the others at the beach he
decides to leave onikawa tomorrow
instead to avoid interactions with more
curse users however suguru was worried
that saturday's curse technique is
taxing his body but gotchu assures
sugudu that his presence makes
everything okay
hayabada and nanami are thrilled to
learn that they also have to stay one
more day on the final day of the escort
riko successfully reaches the foothills
of tokyo jiu jitsu high four hours after
her bounty is lifted they pass through a
number of tortigates putting them inside
jusuhai's barriers with the mission
almost complete goju deactivates his
technique however as soon as he does
he's also stabbed from behind by toji
fushigoro
satoru asks if he knows this man from
somewhere but toji tells him not to
worry about remembering some guy's name
gojo slightly recognizes toji because
earlier on in life while still with the
xenon family taji once went to see the
young gojo boy he was a big deal and was
the first and last person to notice
toji's presence while standing behind
them back in reality toji had waited
until gojo was worn down to strike
stabbing him from behind in a complete
surprise satoru forces himself up into
the air and tsukuru summons his giant
man eating hookworm curse they devour
the sorcerer killer sukuri rushes to his
friend's side but goju assures him that
his wound isn't too severe he reinforced
it with cursed energy to reduce any
further damage gojo asks skedo to take
riko to tenga's place while he takes
care of the assassin he rico and masato
then leave the area as toji slashes his
way out of the giant curse and exercises
it
taji looks around for the star plasma
vessel and claims he's getting rusty for
not killing gojo in one blow
satoru taunts toji stating that the
bounty has been lifted but toji reveals
that he is the one who had made the
bounty in the first place he finds it
funny how they went to onikawa and adds
that he had to create an opening with
the illusion of goals using the time
limits no sorceress from gojo's side
were killed but toji still managed to
get him to deactivate his curse
technique in retaliation saturday
unleashes his curse technique laps blue
on toji seeing him flying using the
magnetic field of attraction however
toji is fast enough to evade this
technique this makes satoru realise that
toji has absolutely zero cursed energy
meaning he's using nothing but an innate
physical prowess to fight saturday can't
read his moves but he is able to knock
toge away once he advances he recognizes
that his opponent knows about the
limitless technique and likely has a
plan toji disappears into the nearby
buildings and saturday can't sense them
without cursed energy he decides to
clear the area of all possible blind
spots using cursed technique laps
maximum cursed energy output bloom the
student believes his enemy may be hiding
in the forest and is surprised when a
random small fly heads appear he
believes they've been kept in the same
cursed spirit that had been storing
fushikura's weapons and toji's plan
might be connected to the curse tool he
took out as well with his view still
blocked by this mock grenade goju plans
on using blue again until he realizes
that toji might have left and gone
straight after rico suddenly togi
appears behind him satsuru notices in
time but his six eyes recognises the
foreign curse energy flowing out of
toji's curse tool this puts saturday on
the defensive almost instantly sealing
his fades togi stabs satsuru through the
neck with a special grey curse tool
inverted spear of heaven this item's
effect is to force the stoppage of all
curse techniques leaving gocho
completely defenseless toji nullifies
satoru's technique and cuts him down
with a flurry of slashes and a flash
leaving the young gojo in a bloody heap
appearing to be dead elsewhere in the
catacombs at the bottom of tokyo jujutsu
high masato says her final goodbyes to
rico they cry and remind each other that
they will always love one another then
suguru stands by to complete the escort
and shows rico to the main hall of the
tomb of the star
suguru then gives rico directions to
master tenkin who is protected by a
barrier that only allows those invited
inside however before she heads off
ghetto gives her the option that she can
either merge with the tengan there or
turn back and return home with them
before the mission began both satoru and
suguru had both agreed that they will
call the mission off if the star
placement vessel didn't agree with the
merger riko had been alone for most of
her life and was different from other
people her parents had died when she was
young so she believed that she would be
okay leaving everyone behind however
after spending time with everyone on the
escort rika cries and admits that she
wants to stay
suguru offers to take riku's hand and
take her home to what she agrees but
sadly she is shot in the head dropping
to the floor and mortifying sugar as
rico's corpse lays on the ground before
ghetto tochi reveals himself and states
that it is time to wrap things up suguru
asks toji why and toji informs him that
he killed satoru gojo
sugri believes him and then a foot of
anger brings out two of his strongest
curse spirits to fight as the battle
begins toshi begins explaining that the
majority of the berries protecting tokyo
jiu-jitsu high are simply hiding it so
long as someone knows their location in
advance they could easily locate the
tomb of the star and the cursed
warehouse sugu attempts to attack toji
with his rainbow dragon and the assassin
fires more rounds at suguru while he
continues talking toshi manages to avoid
suguru's curse and continues explaining
how he managed to infiltrate the school
he swallowed the curse spirit he uses to
store his curse tools allowing him to
stay invisible suguru interrupts toji
demanding he stop talking as he knows
that revealing certain information can
improve his heavenly restriction what he
doesn't know is how he tracked them into
the entrance into the tombs no residuals
were left behind but toji had used more
practical methods of tracking to follow
them his lack of curse energy makes his
five senses sharpen to their peak
allowing him to detect cursed spirits as
well ghetto asks about masato but toji
isn't even sure if she's dead or alive
rainbow dragon then attacks but this
time toji slashes it apart with ease
using his guitar-like curse tool sugru
was shocked by this because his rainbow
dragon had the hardest skin among all of
his cursed spirits toji isn't impressed
by sukuru's technique but he's suddenly
caught inside the second spirit's innate
domain this unwillingly places toji any
pact that will keep their domain there
until the question is answered the
imaginary vengeful spirit asks if she is
pretty but toshi simply replies that she
isn't his type the vengeful spirit
domain instantly disappears allowing
toji to see these scissors floating
around him they are close to his body
ready to cut him apart but toshi
effortlessly deflects all of the blades
with the inverted spear of heaven suguru
comes in close and attempts to absorb
toji's inventory curse but it rejects
him somehow toji draws a second blade
from his curse and slashes both sukuru
and his cursed spirit defeating them
both in an instant toji puts suguru down
and incapacitates him claiming he would
have easily killed him but the
possibility he could release all the
cursed spirits he's taken in upon death
irritates toji still unimpressed toshi
tells suguru to thank his parents for
being born then saying that despite all
their blessings and abilities they all
have lost to a simple monkey who can't
even use jiu-jitsu at the same time in
the foothills of jiu jitsu high goju's
eye twitches showing some signs of life
at the time vessel association
headquarters house of the children of
the star toji delivers the star plasma
vessels corpse to a direct
representative of the star religious
group shigeru sanoda he confirms her
death and states that they will pay toji
extra for his troubles he goes on to
explain that master tengen began
spreading japanese buddhism and the nara
period and preached what would become
the foundation of jiu jitsu sorcerers
the world of jiu-jitsu and religion do
not agree and from that disparity the
time vessel association was born due to
this jiu-jitsu sorceress can't harm the
group while non-curse users are perfect
candidates to work for them the time
vessel association couldn't afford to
allow an impure merger to take place and
they are ready to fall alongside the
star if needed to be toji thinks shigeru
is crazy and asks the man why he didn't
kill the maid instead of using masato's
death he created a false sense of
security from the rescue and in turn
this helped toji they used a private jet
to transport the hostage to onikawa
which toji and the middlemen both think
is hilarious as they two go to leave
toji asks him to go out for food with
him but the man jokingly says that he
only associates with toji in business or
in hell as toji exits the premises he
runs into a restored sataro gojo and is
very surprised to see someone he killed
not too long ago gojo reveals that he
had used a reverse curse technique to
heal himself and claims that toji has
lost for not cutting his head off he
explains over using the six eyes to
process the limitless as well as the
reversed curse technique has taxed his
brain making him delirious with a crazed
demeanor and at the very edge of death
satoru experienced and understood the
core of cursed energy insulted by the
idea that he is lost toji takes out the
inverted spear of heaven and claims that
the battle is just beginning gojo gets
excited agreeing with toji completely
toji attempts to blitz satoru slashing
atoms several times however goju is able
to avoid them and manages to get behind
tochi and levitates into the air toji
turns to face him in time but gojo
learns to flow the reversed curse energy
into their limitless technique to
successfully unleash the curse technique
reversal red the explosion repulsion
power sends tochi flying a great several
hundred meters isasorogojo floats
proudly with an insane smirk on his face
toji acknowledges that his opponent is
indeed a monster
toji stretches out his arm and confirms
that the energy wave satoru used didn't
break any of his bones he then breaks
down each of the logistics behind the
technique of the limitless and fully
believes that none of them are a problem
he connects the inverted sphere of
heaven to a chain and has a plan for
each of the three distinct powers of the
limitless even so an uneasiness lingers
over toji gojo levitates above him
upside down and wearing the same insane
grin despite having lost their previous
fight toji begins to hesitate but
quickly calms down and makes his move to
kill the young sorcerer swinging the
chain wildly in every single direction
gojo then apologizes to rico because
he's not vengeful for her throughout
heaven and earth gojo believes he alone
is the honored one koji creates a dust
wave that forces saturn to float above
it only for the inverted spear of heaven
to appear in front of him
he thinks the attack will likely land so
gochu focuses on countering inheritor
techniques have a manual on how to use
them but it's easy for other clans to
learn how it works as well he knows toji
must be a zening but there is one
technique only known to a few in the
gojo family the hollow technique
combines the motion of blue and the
reversal of red colliding two infinites
that create an imaginary mass that
annihilates everything it touches satoru
unleashes the hollow technique purple
and erases a large portion of toji's
left torso from existence dealing him a
fatal wound and ending their fight
tosi's uneasiness stemmed from him
breaking his own rule he knows he should
have said i don't work for free and made
a run for it but the greatest sorcerer
alive stood before him toji wanted to
discredit it and crush it despite the
jiu jitsu world and his inner family the
self-affirmation caused toji to deviate
from his true self and at that point he
had already lost
unfortunately for him toji was unable to
put aside his petty pride
satoru asks toji for any last words and
he initially claims he doesn't have any
however he then thinks of the young
megamie and tells sautero how his young
son will be sold to the xenon family in
two or three years and to do as he
pleases with that information
sugru makes his way to the house of the
star and is surprised to find toji's
inventory curse injured on the ground he
goes inside to find saturday holding
rico's covered corpse surrounded by the
worshippers applauding her death shocked
by how much saturn has changed suguru
even questions if he's the same person
goju asks if giro feels like killing all
of the non-sorcerers around them because
in his current state of mind he doesn't
think he'd feel anything suguru replies
that that is pointless since the ones in
charge had fled now that the sorcerers
are still involved the time vessel
association can't talk themselves out of
the situation anymore as a group with
problems to begin with the star
religious group will disband with time
gojo questions if there even needs to be
a reason but suguru assures him that it
does especially for jiu jizu sorcerers
one year later in august 2007 gojo
demonstrates to suguru and shoko his
ability to automatically activate and
utilize the infinity he now possesses an
automatic targeting option for jiu jitsu
that can distinguish between mass speed
shape and intensity of fused energy all
in order to ascertain the danger of any
approaching object now gojo can almost
always have the limitless active with
minimal resources normally doing so
would fry his brain but using a reverse
curse technique at the same time keeps
him fresh as cetera tells them about his
other improvements ghetto can't help but
notice that gojo alone became the
strongest now that he can handle any
mission on his own ghetto will be going
on no more assignments alone as well
with the last year's frequent disasters
curses spawned all over japan making it
a busy summer for the sorcerers the
endless cycle of exorcism consumption
using his cursed spirit manipulation was
beginning to weigh on ghetto he began to
lose his way due to the hideous evil of
humanity he wanted to follow through
with his duty as a sorcerer but he
couldn't help but think of all of those
followers of the star as monkeys
after suguru takes a shower he waits
around in a room alone to think until
you hayabada comes to give him some
company he tells him about his far away
mission on the next day and they discuss
souvenirs until suguru asks hayabada if
he's okay with being a sorcerer hayabada
replies that he's not the type to think
about tough questions but giving his all
towards something he can help with
provides a great feeling for him zugudu
agrees and suddenly they're both
confronted by a woman asking him what
kind of girls they are into the woman
walks into the room with suguru and
hayabada suguru questions her identity
what hayabada answers and claims that he
can tell she's not a bad person he
leaves sugar and the woman alone and
shortly after she introduces herself as
the special grade sorcerer yuki sakumo
suguru learned about her as the special
grade who doesn't take on missions and
bums around overseas yuki explains that
jujutsu ends up treating the symptoms of
curses while she wants to get to the
root cause of it all suguru is confused
by what she means by the root of it all
so she explains that she desires a world
where curses do not exist she asks him
what are curses and suguru is able to
explain that curses are born from
negative energy that leaks from humans
and since this is the case there are
only two ways to create a world where
curses don't exist they must either
eradicate cursed energy from all humans
entirely or teach humans to control it
togezinning was a model case for the
former he was the only person yuki had
found all over the entire world that
possessed no cursed energy at all his
heavenly restriction granted him
enhanced senses as well as the ability
to resist curses he truly was a
superhuman and yuki tells suguru that
there's no shame in losing to someone as
powerful as he was yuki wanted to
research him a bit but he refused her
cases of heavenly restriction are so
scarce so yuki decides to focus on the
latter option for eradicating curses you
can inform suguru that other than cases
where sorcerers die and become curses
sorcerers cannot give rise to curses
curse energy does not leak from
sorcerers at nearly the same rate and
flow as non-sorcerers this is due to the
difference in the amount of cursed
energy some sorcerers use and how it
flows while being contained within their
bodies in a general sense if every human
became a sorcerer it would be impossible
for curses to exist shocked and still
haunted by the followers of the star
suguru asks yuki why they shouldn't just
kill every non-sorcerer he snaps out of
it right after that though and yuki
gives him a serious reply
waiting out non-socialist to force
evolution might be the easiest route but
it's also the craziest she asks suguru
if he hates non-sources and he's unable
to give her an answer sukuru used to
believe that sorceress existed to
protect non-sorcerers but now he doesn't
even know if humanity is worth fighting
for yuki confirms that suguru must
choose between looking down on
non-sorcerers and resisting their
failing before getting on her bike and
leaving before heading out on her
motorcycle yuki says to him that she'd
like the three special grades to get
along and reveals that the master tengan
had stabilized
some time later suguru and an army are
in the morgue mourning over hayabada's
death kento believes it was supposed to
be a simple mission to take out a grade
2 cursed spirit however in a far-off
area they traveled to the curse was the
subject of a guardian deities religion
as the deity of that area it became more
powerful and should have been a great
one suguru tells kento to get some rest
and assures him that goji will complete
the mission nanami says that gojo should
take on every mission alone from now on
this makes ghetto think about how being
a sorcerer is like running a marathon
the finish line is too unclear and
there's nothing at the end of the road
but a mountain of fellow sorcerers dead
corpses
next month in september suguru is sent
on a mission to investigate a village
where a cursed spirit had been
kidnapping people and causing abnormal
deaths
suguru is able to exercise the curse but
ends up finding two young girls who had
been beaten and caged suguru tries to
tell them that they are not the cause of
this incident but the non-sorcerers call
them monsters like their parents who
should have died at birth having heard
enough suguru unleashes his cursed
spirits on the people and accepts his
true feelings ghetto murders 112
non-sorcerers and fled the village
afterwards
the original target of his mission the
cursed spirit that had been plaguing any
village was thought to be the culprit
after all the people were found dead
however further investigation revealed
the residuals from suguru's curse
manipulation technique masamiji yaga was
tasked with giving sasudo the horrible
news surrounding sugeru neither of them
can make sense of what happened with
their misguided ally making gojo panic
for the first time in his life
meanwhile in shinjuku shoko is
confronted by suguru while he is smoking
they have a conversation about the
allegations against him with a friendly
tone but shoko is quick to contact
saturday shortly after gojo finds ghetto
walking through the crowd and demands an
explanation just as he told shoko he
wants to build a world without curses
and non-sorcerers not even suguru's
parents were spared making gojo question
sugar's morals ghetto believes that
there is meaning in all of their deaths
but gojo claims that his goal is
pointless but again suguru believes his
friend could do it by himself so it's
not impossible
if they could switch places the
impossible could become possible ghetto
decides to leave after confirming that
this is the life that he has chosen
ghido says that gojo should kill him if
he wants since there is meaning in that
too and as suguru walks away with the
crowd gojo begins to aim his hollow
purple technique at him however gojo
ends up being unable to kill his best
friend allowing gero to get away he
meets up with masumichi later and
reveals that he was unable to take
suguru out
even though gojo was the strongest he
realized that he can only save those
prepared to be saved at the building
that once served as the time vessel
association's headquarters ghetto comes
before a new congregation made up of the
remnants of the star religious group and
like-minded people suguru wishes to talk
them all over
serving as priests who can free people
of their curses this way he can collect
money and curses at the same time there
are numerous voices of opposition so
suguru makes an example out of sonoda by
brutally smashing him on the stage the
next time he addresses the crowd he
isn't as friendly he demands that all of
the monkeys obey him
elsewhere saturday gojo finds a young
megami for shiguro the young megamie
questions this strange man and asks why
he's looking at him strangely satoru
appears annoyed because megami looks
exactly like toji as the two speak goju
tells megami that his father is from the
xenon family which he left to have his
son this hidden clan loves people
blessed with a curse technique and
megami is approaching the age where his
curse technique will manifest which
makes it perfect time to sell him to the
zenings this was toji's trump card
against them which is unfortunate for
mega me the first grader replies that he
doesn't care about his father and his
mother tsukumi hasn't returned in a
while either he believes that they use
the divorce money to run off together
and live happily without him satoru asks
megami if he wants to go to the zenon
family but the boy is only worried about
what will happen to his sister zazuru
taunts him about it to get a rise out of
megami and when the youngster gives him
a fair scout for insisting he insists
that there is no way sukumi would be
happy at the zenin family which leaves
saturday satisfied he promises then to
take care of things for megami and asks
him instead to get strong eleven years
later in the present on october 19th
2018 gojo sensei wakes up from his train
and all of these past events in his life
he awakens to his three students
including megami looking at him gojo
smirks at his longtime protege proud of
how he's grown since then which confuses
megan me
so that officially brings us to the very
end of the gojo past arc or hidden
inventory arc of jiu-jitsu kaizen kind
of whichever you want to call it i guess
the anime is probably going with hidden
inventory by the looks of it and the
manga is sticking with gojo pasta from
my memory so if you guys have enjoyed
the video obviously be sure to check a
comment down below and let me kind of
know
what kind of arcs and stuff you want me
to go over in the future for different
series and all that kind of stuff the
next arc that i will be going over is
going to be obviously i think it's the
bat devil arc of chainsaw man uh for all
my like tokyo avengers guys out there
i've still got the tokyo avengers like
script to do oh no i've pretty much done
the script now it's kind of just gotta
like edit it up and finish it off and
then i'll be able to kind of record that
video and start editing the actual
footage for it as well uh it's just a
lot longer than i expected it to
actually be
as it's like 40 chapters or something
and this video was only like 15. so you
can see it's probably going to be around
an hour hour and a half long
but heaps of videos to to come in the
future for like arcs explain but just
make sure you chuck down in the comment
section below so i can see kind of what
series you guys are most interested in
seeing in the future but yeah obviously
this arc is extremely stellar but at the
same time it's actually pretty sad as
you kind of see gesso go from the the
smarter one i guess you could say out of
the two being the one with more brains
realizing that you know they shouldn't
do specific things because it's against
the normal morals of what people should
do and him going to question his own
like morals and what has you believe in
life and him going from being this nice
dude to being someone who belittles
people and calls the monkeys at the end
of you know just 14 chapters here is
completely utterly crazy so you know and
it hits me kind of differently you know
like on some days when i read through
this arc it's like damn like it's really
dark at the
actual center of it like gojo did not
have a good
like gojo did not have a good time uh
starting off i guess you could say at
the jiu jitsu college losing you know
some of his friends and then obviously
what happens later on with uh ghetto is
just terrible you have seen the movie or
my previous youtube video
but yeah anyway oh and on there if you
have noticed my other juicy carson video
got taken down another one whoa but um
we're gonna get that back obviously it's
just gonna take time as per usual it'll
be back up in like two weeks i'd say and
six hour long video got taken down
yeah another one another one of the
books but yeah
it'll be back up as well but anyway if
you guys have enjoyed the video and want
to see more stuff just like this then
make sure you comment down below like i
have said a million times before in
every other old video and make sure you
leave it a like as well and if you're on
your own here make sure you know like do
obviously hit that subscribe button so
you can keep up to date with your
favorite manga or just you know anime
when i decide to go over it and if you
want to kind of watch it and have a
refresher or that kind of stuff then hit
it down below but if not for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i will see you all in a bit
bye
[Music]
you